chapter 6 a.i
coach the first principle is that you
must not fool yourself
and you are the easiest person to fool
richard feynman above
all else show the data
edward tufte in
our near future we will have
personalized ai
coaches that fuse data across our lives
and provide us with unique insights into
evolving
our consciousness and maximizing our
full potential
ai coaches are scale invariant so
states countries and our world will have
these rich
data visualization operating systems
to make much more well-informed
decisions
data is the new oil is a common mantra
of the tech literate
the ai coach is fusing the data are
inevitable
the bigger question is will we have
architected the inclusive protocols
that enable shared wealth creation in
this radically lucrative emerging market
our current data interoperability
standards between major tech
companies both domestically and
internationally
needs to shift we need to imagine
planet earth as one organism where tech
companies
and governments need high levels of
efficient
intracellular communication in order to
procure the
insights in a harmonized way that mimics
the genius of biological symbiosis
evolution of consciousness whatever
perfection the collective
seeks can come only by the perfection of
the
individuals who constitute it sri
aurobindo
the unfolding of consciousness
jean gepsir we too
frequently talk about where individuals
rank
in the wealth hierarchy without
mentioning where they rank
in the enlightenment hierarchy this is a
bold call out
of the most powerful people on the
planet to be the first to have their
biometric correlates of awakening
analyzed many of our most upstream
problems may simply be egoic
consciousness
in leadership there is a lot of power
concentrated in the hands of a couple
thousand world leaders
who have little incentive to inclusively
stakehold the rest of humanity as we
enter the ai
age these are the same world leaders who
need to be held
paramountly responsible for the
execution of the sdgs
and the sustainable next generation
architectures
take the enlightened sages of the planet
say people that teach the planetary
mystic traditions
then catalog their biometric correlates
into the highest meta pattern
so we have a directional reference for
how to nudge people
we already know thanks to the work of
myriad scientists like claire graves don
beck
chris cowan ken wilbur jean piaget
lawrence kolberg john gebser james
fowler eric erickson
sriarubindo and mira alfassa that
generally
stages of consciousness development go
ego social ethno
world transpersonal and
non-dual as rupert spyra says
everyone deserves imperturbable peace
and causeless joy
and as sri aurobindo says we need to
anchor these spiritual awakenings in
the knot of life